coming up on Star Talk special edition
this one is on addiction
and we have as our special guest Anna
Lemke she's a professor of Psychiatry at
Stanford University and we discuss
social media is that addicting if it is
how does it addict us we also talk about
other emergent modern addictions like
gambling we've always known it was out
there but now it seems to be more
prevalent than ever we talk about the
science of dopamine how it works in what
parts of your brain and can we control
it should we control it why is it there
at all where did it come from
evolutionarily
all that and more on Star Talk
[Music]
this is Star Talk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here you're a personal astrophysicist
and today it's a StarTalk special
edition
completely
completely devoted to addiction what
it's what does it mean what role does it
play in our lives and is it good is it
bad where did it come from where is it
going and I before we introduce our
special guest for this let me get my
co-host here Chuck Nice Chuck hey Neil
all right of addiction
Chuck Nice
okay fine okay we got Gary O'Reilly Gary
hi Neil hey good Gary former Soccer Pro
and soccer sports announcer and we got
him for our show we're borrowing him
from all the others from all the others
so Gary you you put you and your fellow
producers put this show together what do
you have in mind for us and are you are
you reaching out for help Gary
is this a clandestine Cry for Help yeah
yeah this is this is all it's all about
me darling yeah
um so
there are many things that we can get
addicted to which is alcoholics drugs
it's gambling the latest is endless food
and anything and food so
there are modern addictions which we
will get into later into the show I mean
there's that point where you ask the
question does the Relentless pursuit of
pleasure always lead to pain what role
does dopamine and serotonin play in
addiction I have our minds being
manipulated and tricked
into addictive behavioral patterns and
what can be done to avoid what can we do
with our brains and stop them being
rewired in sort of a case of social
media so for that we're going to need
someone really rather special chief of
Stanford addiction medicine dual
diagnosis clinic at Stanford University
author of drug dealer MD and also
dopamine Nation may I introduce Anna
Lemke Anna Collective welcome to
StarTalk thank you for inviting me I'm
happy to be here
yeah and we learned that your your
background is as a psychiatrist so you
can authentically prescribe medicines in
ways that many therapists cannot that's
kind of doctor
only the best but I'll give you the good
drug I'm delighted that you exist in
this capacity because there's so it's
taken such a toll on society not only in
the past but especially most recently
and let's let's take our first segment
and and focus on dopamine first is is
there such a thing
as um an addictive personality do some
people release more dopamine than others
when subject to the same stimulus
the short answer is yes yes
[Applause]
we but we don't use that terminology
anymore the the terminology the addicted
personality now now we talk more about
people being vulnerable to addiction or
having a genetic load for addiction
um so we think of it more in the sort of
disease model or the disease diaphysis
rather than you know this person's
personality that makes sense when you
think about it because if you make it
about a person's personality then what
you're doing is you're handing over
control of the addiction to the person
when addiction is just the opposite of
that you will never meet an addict who
says hey man I lost all my teeth I lost
my job I can't see my kids but this is
great I'm in control
yeah yeah so what is dopamine
specifically
so dopamine is a chemical that we make
in our brains it has many different
functions but one of the most important
functions is that it's Central to the
experience of pleasure reward and
motivation and it may be even more
important for motivation than for actual
pleasure itself right but but what do I
hear about serotonin when I hear about
serotonin it's just synonymous with
dopamine
it's not synonymous but serotonin and
dopamine are both neurotransmitters
neurotransmitters are the molecules that
bridge the gap between synapses to allow
for finer tuning of our electrical
circuits that make us who we are and so
dopamine and serotonin are related they
have distinct functions however and
although serotonin is involved in
mediating addiction to certain types of
substances and behaviors dopamine is
considered the final common pathway for
all reinforcing substances and behaviors
which is why neuroscientists tend to use
it as a kind of universal currency for
measuring addiction so what triggers the
release what triggers the release
professor of the dopamine because it
can't just be you know what Brian says
you have that now something must be
where is it triggering and what's it
well there you will why can't it yeah so
so dopamine is released in response to
reinforcing substances and behaviors and
by reinforcing I mean things that uh are
something that we deem necessary for
survival that typically feel good or
that our brains tell us this is
important you need to pay attention to
it so even like novelty a dopamine is
very sensitive to novelty and newness
but for example intoxicants the sort of
difference between something that is
thought of as a drug or as very
addictive and something that's thought
of as not particularly addictive is how
much dopamine is released in the reward
pathway and how quickly it's released
and substances and behaviors that are
highly addictive release a lot of
dopamine all at once in this dedicated
part of the brain called the reward
pathway
right right okay reward pathway new
phrase phrase of the day so far
um what do we what do we call it what is
a reward Pathways it's simple as it's
transmitter it's a it's how the delivery
system works
well one of the exciting findings in
Neuroscience in the past hundred years
or so is the discovery of a dedicated
circuit in the brain that is Central to
this reward function this this
motivation function it consists broadly
of the nucleus accumbens and the ventral
tegmental area these are sort of basal
forebrain nuclear structures and then
the prefrontal cortex that large gray
matter area right behind our foreheads
so that's a gross oversimplification
it's a very complex pathway but but
that's you know in sort of
reductionistic way what the reward
pathway consists of and that that area
is very rich in dopamine releasing
neurons right so so you you gave us the
location in the brain where that occurs
is what you're saying there is that
right that's right
okay but it's also that that
prefrontal core set cortex is also
attached to our executive function right
exactly right yes yeah so so that when
that gets hijacked then that puts us at
risk of not being able to make the right
decisions or to say no when we should
say no or to be extremely capricious
without even realizing why we're doing
it yeah very well said so the prefrontal
cortex is Central to the ability to
delay gratification to appreciate future
consequences to tell autobiographical
narratives or stories and you might
think of the prefrontal cortex as the
brakes on the car and then the nucleus
accumbens and ventral tegmental area
which is really rich in dopamine
releasing neurons as the accelerator so
addiction is some kind of problem either
with the brakes or the accelerator or
both
wow right so doctor come across the
phase phrase rather phase as well of
dopamine Rush
um
I'll handle this one for you doc uh yeah
Gary that's called come here not that
one okay
Chuck will take it from here yeah
okay all right I'm with you so they say
when you get Love Struck it's about a
dopamine rush so if we're falling in
love Are We Now is it kind of that in
the form of addiction
so maybe I can go back to some basic
science experiments looking at least the
response in terms of the release of
dopamine to various stimuli so we're
always releasing dopamine at a kind of
Baseline tonic level it's sort of like
the heartbeat of the brain in some sense
but experiments in which a probe was
stuck deep into this reward circuitry in
rodents to measure dopamine release in
response to different stimuli showed
that dopamine firing increased above
Baseline 50 percent in response to
Chocolate a hundred percent in response
to sex 150 percent in response to
nicotine something like 225 in response
to cocaine and approximately a thousand
percent in response to methamphetamine
and indeed if if you match that
behaviorally to whether or not a rodent
will press a lever to get that substance
or to engage in that behavior you find
that the more dopamine that's released
the more more likely that red is to
press that lever until it dies and when
it gets when it comes to meth they just
rip the lever out of them right
essentially essentially now there is
there is something a little artifactual
about that in the sense that the way
that meth works is to directly increase
dopamine within the synapse whereas
something like food or sex Works through
other chemical Cascades like serotonin
for example as we talked about but the
final common pathway again for all of
these is to release dopamine which is
why neuroscientists like to use it as
this kind of common currency and and
that goes back to what you were saying
earlier about motivation so when we eat
we get a little hit of dopamine because
that satisfaction allows us to say hey I
should do this again otherwise we would
just not eat it would be like yeah
whatever who cares you know which is why
sometimes when people are really
depressed one of the things they do not
do is eat right yeah very well said and
and furthermore if I eat a piece of
broccoli I personally will get very
little dopamine release most likely but
if I neither does anyone
right exactly exactly but but if I yeah
I said it
cupcake I'll get a lot more dopamine but
now qualifying the broccoli idea if I
haven't eaten for two days and you give
me a piece of broccoli that's gonna
that's gonna be really yummy to me right
that's gonna release more dopamine
um at least from what we know my
Baseline then then not I thought it was
really important that that Chuck talked
about sort of other contextual factors
like depression right which then sort of
sort of hypothetically decrease Baseline
dopamine firing levels such that not
almost everything loses its salience or
its attractiveness likewise other
co-occurring mental health disorders can
have other impacts on our experience of
reward it's thought for example that
people with attention deficit disorder
might be a relatively insensitive to
dopamine firing which is why they maybe
tend to be sensation Seekers and need
more rewards to get any kind of response
at all everybody's got a different
Baseline it's a baseline thing yeah
that's right every every everybody's got
a difference what I wanted to ask you
Professor was
with the meth being as addictive as it
is is it working purely to to detonate
the dopamine or does it have other
little techniques it's that are engaging
and triggering
well it's yeah it's you know the the
talk about dopamine is like an
oversimplification of a very complex
process
um you know math Works through other
chemical Cascades other
neurotransmitters also you know when we
uh when we look at these experiments in
rodents you know rodents at the end of
the day are not people and our brains
are much more complex and we cannot
ignore the very important concept of
drug of choice which is to say my
particular wiring might lead me to be
more attracted to certain types of
reinforcers that are different from what
your particular brain is wired for such
that I might work very very hard uh you
know to repeat the experience I have on
social media but not necessarily for
meth or alcohol or something else
because my wiring is just my wiring
right yeah that's that's that's so wild
because you hear people say it all the
time well I shouldn't say you hear
people say it all the time I've heard
people say it often where oh I tried
this and it just did nothing for me
right it just didn't yeah yeah you know
I tried to have alcohol but it did
nothing for me or you know I I smoked
marijuana once it did I mean it just
didn't do a damn thing to me I got
sleepy and that was it so you know if
that's what you're talking about which
is exactly kind of fascinating yeah
fascinating
but Anna what about what of this what of
the
uh the stereotype
depressed person who just broke up with
okay a woman just breaks up with her
boyfriend and you see her this is in
movies all the time in rom-coms where
she's sitting on the bed eating a box of
chocolates looking at some sad movie so
they're eating in that case rather than
not eating is that a different kind of
depression that responds so they're
they're basically compensating for that
loss of pleasure because now that all
they have access access to is a box of
chocolates
yeah so there are many different risk
factors for addiction but one very
well-known risk factor is severe stress
so if we have some kind of giant
stressor in our life it's very natural
for us to reflexively turn to substances
or behaviors that will release those
feel-good neurotransmitters as a way to
cope or compensate one of my favorite
experiments in the Neuroscience
literature in rodents is a rodent or a
group of rodents was trained to press a
lever for intravenous cocaine and and
rats and mice will press that lever
until exhaustion or death if you then
take the cocaine away eventually that
behavior of pressing that lever will
extinguish which is to say they'll stop
pressing the lever but if you then
expose that rat or that mouse to a
severe painful foot shock the rodent
will immediately run over to the lever
and start pressing it again whoa
so that's a very nice
Paradigm for what we as humans do that
you know stressor is something that can
kick off exacerbate contribute to
maladaptive consumptive consumptive
behaviors and for people who are in
recovery or abstaining from their drug
of choice if they then experience acute
stressor they will almost reflexively
turn to or want to turn to you know
their addictive behaviors as a way to
shore themselves up again fascinating
but did you use them how do you like it
Chuck it's amazing did you use the
phrase maladaptive consumptive behavior
isn't that the same thing as overeating
yeah so maladaptive Behavior can apply
too
yeah I just oh look okay or something
that might not otherwise be good for you
whether or not it's food
hi I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and I'm Lindsay Nix
Walker senior producer of StarTalk and
Neil and I just co-authored a brand new
StarTalk book coming out September 12th
yeah this is the third in a series of
collaborations with National Geographic
books and this one is titled to infinity
and beyond and it's available for
pre-order from the StarTalk website
startalkmedia.com
books if you pre-order it you get to
gain access to a live stream that
Lindsay Walker and I will do from this
office and you have the occasion to
submit questions that we will answer
that's right if you pre-order from
startalkmedia.com books we'll answer
your questions about the book The
Universe Neil's favorite kind of cheese
whatever you want
all right so we'll see you there and
we'll see you then
so Professor is there a way naturally or
through intervention chemically to
regulate to manage this dopamine release
rather than just have it gushing and be
out of control sure I mean that's that's
what treatment and Recovery is all about
um we think of addiction as a
biopsychosocial disease that means there
are biological psychological and social
risk factors and we have to intervene at
the biological psychological and social
level so in terms of the biological
level we have medicines that can treat
addiction for example we use a medicine
that blocks opioid receptors and it's
FDA approved not just to treat opioid
addiction but also alcohol addiction
because we know that alcohol works not
just on the Gaba systems but also on our
endogenous opioid systems and by
blocking the opioid receptor what we're
probably doing is blocking the
reinforcing effects of alcohol such that
people will describe that when they
drink alcohol while they're taking
Naltrexone it just doesn't taste as good
they're not as interested in having
another drink which is great because we
can use it then to help people not just
abstain but to moderate their use so
that's one example of a biological
intervention psychological inventions
there are many one of the things we
teach people is to kind of surf their
urges or think through the drink so
these are like mindfulness practices so
that they can learn to identify their
triggers not react to those triggers to
distance themselves to weight those
triggers out and then in terms of social
interventions we you know 12 steps
Alcoholics Anonymous
Narcotics Anonymous other 12-step groups
is basically
a way to contextualize and socialize
recovery so that you're in a sober
social networks that you can reach out
to another person when you're having
urges or cravings and then that person
can help you co-regulate that's just one
example of how how 12-step works yeah
but if you if you know that there's
chemistry going on in the brain why
would 12 steps work at all
well because 12-step changes brain
chemistry and we don't just yeah yeah
okay is it is it is it more the social
interaction or is it the disciplines uh
that they introduced to your life or is
it merely having a community around you
that uh you're familiar with that
understands you that brings you
compassion uh all these things that we
tend to take for granted when we're
living in normal social sets I really
think it's all of the above so I think
it's the foundational philosophy the uh
Shifting the locus of control from
inside of us to a power outside of
ourselves something greater than
ourselves doesn't have to be a deified
entity it could just be the 12-step
Community it's the working of the steps
all 12 of them including especially step
four where we acknowledge what we have
contributed to the problem and what our
Character defects are which allow us to
create a more valid narrative about our
lives which then also gives us access to
more information to make better choices
going forward and then of course it is
the social network both the D shaming
that happens when you interact with
other people struggling with addiction
but also as I as I talk about in in my
book dopamine Nation a kind of
leveraging the shame within the group
such that people would not want to
relapse because they would want to have
to come back and declare themselves as
as a newcomer something that I I label
pro-social shame so Professor when
you've got these Pathways and the
dopamine is running and you talk about
drug of choice what else is out there
that's triggering apart from some very
obvious well-known ones well it's
important to recognize that you can get
addicted not just to substances that we
ingest but also behaviors that we do and
because this uh motivational reward
pathway is conserved over millions of
years of evolution across species it's
really fundamental to survival and to
get us to be motivated to do anything so
theoretically
theoretically you could get addicted to
just about anything and and what we are
seeing in the Modern Age especially as
more and more substances and behaviors
have been made more potent more
reinforcing more novel more accessible
and coming greater and greater
quantities is that we're seeing people
get addicted to all kinds of things
today that we would not have imagined
possible in Prior Generations so now is
it is it
still considered an addiction if the
behavior itself is not only acceptable
but maybe beneficial I'm I get up every
day by the way this is an example people
this is not my life I get up every day
at six a.m and I head straight to the
gym because I can't my day isn't right
unless I get up and head straight to the
gym and I do that if I could do it seven
days a week I do it seven days a week if
I could go twice a day I'd go twice a
day you know you know if you meet a
person like that I mean the behavior is
seen as good so we don't say hey man you
you might have a problem
yeah an excellent point and a good
opportunity to Define addiction
addiction is the continued compulsive
use of a substance or behavior despite
harm to self and or others so just very
broadly speaking if we're diagnosing
addiction we have to identify that it's
doing some kind of harm it might be a
harm that that person sees for them
themselves it may be a harm that they
don't recognize but that other recognize
others recognize having said that you
are absolutely right that this is
contextualized within a given time and
place and that if Society has deemed
certain behaviors healthy even when
people do them to the detriment of uh
that their own health potentially or or
the other other people's harm then we
might not call it an addiction and you
use exercise of that and people can
actually get addicted to exercise you
know where they're continuing to engage
in that activity despite being injured
despite not spending time doing other
things that they value
workaholism is another great example
people who are compulsively focused on
work money achievement and one that we
celebrate in our culture and that we
usually don't call out so addiction is
an interesting field because there is
this what I think it's a fascinating
intersection between culture and biology
so Professor if it's something this core
and necessary for life
say water
how about then
well um so
yeah and if you're addicted to water you
are the most boring person in the world
you need help
it is tasteless it has zero calories
right
yes so Professor has that has that been
uh a notified addiction yeah so I've
seen one case of that in my career um it
was actually very sad it was a woman
with a very severe alcohol addiction who
got into recovery from her alcohol
addiction
um that is to say she was no longer
consuming alcohol she was actively
working on her health but somehow or
another she discovered that if she drank
water in copious amounts she could feel
altered and she got addicted to that
process and ultimately died of hypo well
she she had several very severe severe
episodes of hyponatremia and it almost
died from those episodes washing out the
electrolytes you can't drink that kind
of water no no yeah that's it's very
dangerous holy crap I was only joking
now I feel like a jackass no no it's
okay that's right but we're all learning
yeah we are all learning especially so
you think you guys are the worst
so Professor Ben there's this term sort
of dopamine cleansing dopamine fasting
um does that didn't I used to call that
cold turkey or something similar back in
the day yeah I haven't turned that term
lately culture dopamine fasty and and
cold turkey yeah I haven't called talk
nobody does anything cold turkey anymore
yeah that used to that used to mean that
you had the right stuff
so we still do do um you know ask people
to quit cold turkey as long as they're
not at risk for life-threatening
withdrawal it's important to remember
that people with severe physiologic
dependence to alcohol
benzodiazepines like Xanax or in some
cases opioids can have such a severe
withdrawal syndrome that they could
actually die from that withdrawal
syndrome so we would not ask ask that of
people who were at risk of of a
life-threatening withdrawal we also
wouldn't ask people to stop abruptly if
they had tried repeatedly to do that on
their own and weren't able to but it is
an intervention that we do use as kind
of an early intervention for people who
are
a little bit addicted all the way up to
moderately addicted but not yet severely
physiologically dependent and we asked
them typically you know in clinic to
sort of try to wrap their heads around
stopping for 30 days because 30 days is
on average the amount of time it takes
to sort of reset these dopamine reward
Pathways and to sort of get that
prefrontal cortex back online and be
able to make informed decisions about
what they want to do going forward okay
we've talked about dopamine and how if
it gushes and rushes you know we've got
a problem that we we battle to control
what if naturally occurring within
people's bodies there's not enough
as you said that Baseline
what happens then what what because it's
got to be a detrimental effect if it's
below base so what what conditions come
forward if there is like I say a lack of
dopamine in the body well you know this
is
um there's not a whole lot of
um deep understanding of this yet but
but some preliminary data suggests that
depression is characterized by low
levels of dopamine transmission as I
said before there's some thinking that
people with attention deficit disorder
might at Baseline have lower levels of
dopamine transmission making them less
sensible or sensitive to rewards
um
and we also know very importantly that
with repeated exposure to highly
reinforcing substances and behaviors
that release a lot of dopamine all at
once the brain tries to adapt to that
increased dopamine firing by down
regulating dopamine transmission not
just to Baseline levels but actually
below Baseline levels so if you're a
person who abuses a drug that floods
your brain with dopamine
then your brain says oh man we're making
too much dopamine we gotta chill out on
this dopamine production so then you
stop doing the drug and all of a sudden
you have no dopamine where you should
have dopamine and does that mean at that
point you're like man I need some drugs
because I need some some dopamine that's
exactly right Chuck you said it this you
said it really really well and and more
clearly than I could have
um so Anna why do we have you when we
have Chuck he could have just
honestly I've been thinking that myself
this whole time I was like the comedian
could basically give the talk okay um
yeah that's exactly what happens is that
with with repeated use of the the same
or similar reinforcing substance and
behaviors we eventually end up in this
kind of dopamine deficit State now we
need more of our drug and more important
forms over time not to get high but just
to feel normal and stop the craving
which is exactly why people with severe
addiction will relapse even weeks after
they've stopped using even though they
can objectively tell you yes my life is
much better because I'm not not using
and my my spouse is back and my job is
back and I you know from a physical
health point of view I'm doing better
but mentally many of them are still
struggling with those Universal symptoms
of that dopamine deficit state which are
anxiety irritability insomnia depression
and craving and craving manifests in
many different ways it can be
ruminations to want to use it can be
long-winded narratives that are
essentially rationalizations for why I
should use so craving is is really
really a Wily kind of thing that swims
through our brain and Catches Us unaware
so Anna if if for some reason dopamine
stopped getting made entirely does that
itself have consequences is that the
life of a depressed person or is there
some other symptoms of that
it depends what part of the brain
dopamine production decreased in so for
example if we had a decrease in dopamine
production in the part of the brain
called the substantia which is a
discrete and separate part from the
reward pathway then we would end up with
Parkinson's disease which is a movement
disorder so dopamine as I said has
different functions and it's also very
essential for movement and it's probably
no coincidence that the same
neurotransmitter that's important for
movement is also important for pleasure
reward and motivation because we
typically need to move our bodies in
order to get the reward that we want
Unfortunately today that's no longer
necessarily true we're now living in a
time and place when we can just sit on
the couch and swipe right and swipe left
and have it delivered to the doorstep
wait so why can't you reverse engineer
that and cure Parkinson's you said
there's a section of the brain if it
stops making dopamine you we have
Parkinson's so why not introduce
dopamine back into the brain and then
cure Parkinson's that way
so that's in effect how we do treat
Parkinson's um with uh so if I gave you
if you had Parkinson's and I gave you
dopamine a spoonful of dopamine it would
do absolutely nothing because it doesn't
cross the blood-brain barrier so instead
I have to give you something called
l-dopa which is a dopamine precursor
that does cross the blood-brain barrier
and then that gets converted into
dopamine which then gives you more
dopamine in the substantia Nigro which
then allows you to have more fluid
movements to counteract the disease of
Parkinson's unfortunately it binds
non-specifically throughout the brain so
that means that that that dopamine I
gave you is now binding to dopamine
receptors in the reward pathway and we
see is about a quarter of people treated
with l-dopa for Parkinson's end up with
some kind of compulsive consumptive
Behavior like pathological gambling
pathological shopping
Etc
well let's let's pick up some of the
modern addictions that we see with
gambling as as legal lately as it's ever
been I you know I see ads I see and then
of course the ads are accompanied with a
little phone number at the bottom have a
gambling problem call this and I just
think to myself we have people
exploiting the susceptibility of
innocent members of the general public
to gambling urges and I'm saddened by
this because they're they're hijacking
our neurochemistry to make this happen
and of course that also brings up social
media the addiction to how many likes
you're gonna get what
could you just reflect on this modern
emergence of addiction relative to the
classical addictions we all grew up with
yeah so I'm I'm equally sad and I agree
with you that these corporations are
really praying on people who are
vulnerable to addiction and also making
us all broadly speaking more vulnerable
to addiction
um one of the biggest risk factors for
addiction that people often discount is
simple access if you live in a
neighborhood where drugs are sold on the
street corner you're more likely to try
them and you're more likely to get
addicted to them and what we're seeing
with gambling especially for example
online sports betting which has now
become legal in multiple states in the
union is that in those States we're
seeing a 300 to 500 percent increase in
calls to pathological gambling hotlines
so it's very clear that as gambling
becomes more accessible especially
through a mobile app we are going to
have more people who are struggling with
gambling addiction and very sadly I
would add to that that these
corporations actually often specifically
pray on people who get addicted to
gambling so they track those people and
they pursue them and they proffer they
will actually they can track them yeah
they give them money they give them
money to allow them to gamble and they
they also change the algorithm to make
sure that they win early on and then by
getting them hooked then they're it's
really it's very it's a classic drug
dealer move that's right that's the
oldest line in the book is the first one
is always free right exactly right
exactly so it's really it's really uh
it's very distressing so Professor you
talked about movement being a trigger
right historically in our Primal brain
we are now the Primal brain that we have
is now fighting some serious modern
technology so I'm going to upgrade to
cartoon garish colors I'm going to give
you a movement I'm going to give you how
many other strategies are out there but
are keeping my attention because that's
the for me the product that's generated
in social media is my attention time
right new currency yeah yeah that is it
so how how are they making sure I am
utterly fixated yes and please take your
time explaining this so that I can take
notes for my own social media accounts
all right
yeah so so you're getting at uh you know
what what is one of the huge issues uh
in considering these digital devices and
these digital media as um as having
genuine product liability just the way
that we think of cigarettes as being
having inherent harm there's now a shift
toward thinking about the inherent harm
of digital media of All Sorts because of
the built-in design functions and I
think the first and foremost the design
function of 24 7 portable accessibility
that increases access wherever we are
whenever we are has made an enormous
impact on the addictive potential and
the number of people struggling with
digital addiction addiction to
technology and to the Internet so in the
early 2000s with the Advent of uh you
know smartphones
we saw a huge increase in the number of
people struggling with addictive
pathological gambling pornography
viewing and then as time went on we
started to see video addictive video
game use addictive shopping addictive
social media use and now we can take it
with them it's with them at all times
that's right that's a huge part of it
that people I think really don't fully
appreciate and it's important to realize
that because that means that the
intervention is going to be separating
ourselves for some period of time every
day from our digital devices and that's
what we're not doing we're basically
almost cybernetically enhanced with our
devices with us at all time but that's
so true because in the 80s when I was
growing up if you if you wanted to take
porn with you that was really quite an
undertaking all right good luck good
luck right
yes so Professor how do you ensure
security of the Mind particularly I like
that phrase the younger age groups I
like that phrase yeah and how do you get
that
holistic protection
what what levels of Engagement and where
does it come from for this to be
something we can carry forward you've
got to lock your kids in a box yeah so
yeah exactly wait a minute you don't do
that already am I the only one that does
that wait
I think JK Rowling got there before
Harry Potter upstairs yeah I mean first
of all I want to say that this is both
an individual problem and a collective
problem that means we we need both
bottom-up Solutions where we
individually change our habits and our
as as individuals and as families but we
also need you know top-down
interventions schools corporations that
make and profit from the media and the
devices the federal government who can
impose regulations it needs to be coming
from both ends in order for us to get a
handle on this huge uh worldwide
Collective problem and specifically in
terms of what can be done beyond the
kinds of individual and family
interventions that I talk about in my
book when you think about it from a
policy perspective I think about it as
in three three categories we can try to
change the design which is what you were
talking about earlier Gary
um this idea of like the bottomless
Bowls the flashing lights the AI
algorithms that learn what we've liked
before and then push content uh similar
but slightly different than what we've
watched before which then keeps people's
engagement their attention makes it more
compulsive pushes them to extreme
versions more potent versions so you
know we need we need to change the
design in order to decrease the
liability of the products we also need
to think about access so you know
limiting access as we've talked about
it's not just what we're doing online
it's the sheer quantity and frequency of
viewing that screen which is changing
our brains and leading to morbidity and
mortality and when I think of access a
really low hanging fruit in my opinion
is the school system it seems to me very
obvious that children should not be
having their smartphones with them
during school school hours especially
not during class but also potentially
not at all and what we're seeing is some
schools typically private schools that
have more resources have taken phones
away and given their students flip
phones and what you're hearing is you're
hearing about huge improvements in
student well-being and student mental
health you're hearing teachers and
administrators say the schools are noisy
again why because kids are engaging with
each other so so this is so flip phone
is just a phone it's not right it's
boring it's boring a kid's not gonna
gonna spend their time on a flip phone
but they can't complain that they don't
have phone access to an emergency right
that's exactly right that's exactly
right so how much of this is covered in
your dopamine Nation book which came out
just a couple of years ago
dopamine Nation focuses very much on
what we as individuals and we as
families can do and it describes in
simple terms the Neuroscience of what's
happening and why we get addicted to
potentially almost anything and then
specifically steps that we can take so
it's not much focused on policy but
since it came out I've been more and
more involved in policy
discussions and you know trying to
consider what can be done beyond the
level of the individual and the
individual family and what what about
family policy because I'm sure right now
anybody who's a parent who is listening
to this is thinking it's impossible for
me to stop my kids or get get them off
of the video game to get them off of the
tablet to stop them from and by the way
there's social media companies now push
out all the content everywhere so if you
keep your kids off of X Twitter whatever
that is or Facebook or whatever they're
just going to get it on YouTube or
YouTube shorts or whatever so or on
Discord or so what do you do to like
curtail aside from the Draconian measure
of ripping the phone away from them what
do you do to curtail their behavior you
put them in a box
we already talked that yeah so we moved
on from that
yeah you know you don't put the kid in
the box but you probably should put the
devices in a box oh so you you are an
advocate of literally snatching it away
from them so let me let me qualify that
for kids up until a certain age
and I would say this is usually around
11 or 12. I believe that we as parents
still have enough control generally
speaking in the household especially if
we're co-parenting with somebody that
agrees with us and we you know we can
organize it together and I think it's
very possible and also good to sit down
as a family and say hey we've been using
devices in this way but it's not healthy
and here are the reasons why and so as a
family we need to make some changes and
I've seen families do this and it can be
very distressing for all comers because
very often parents are as addicted as
kids but to do it together as a family
with younger children can be so healthy
for families to just really reorient it
doesn't mean your kids never on the
device but it's on they're on the device
for a limited quantity of time after
they've done their chores and their
schoolwork as a kind of thing that
they've earned for good behavior for a
limited amount of time and not every day
and then not every day is really key if
you want a number of hours there's some
general consensus less than two hours a
day
yeah exactly you but it's important it's
important to get in there while they're
little because it lays the foundation
for you know their wiring and their scat
and their neurological scaffolding that
they're going to be left with their in
the rest of their adult lives now once
kids get to be about 13
it's it they're no longer in your
control they're gonna do what they're
gonna do but at that point what we can
do as parents is model the behavior that
we want to see give them feedback on
what we're observing use contingency
management which is punishments and
rewards to incentivize uh you know the
kinds of behaviors that we want to see
and just talk about it openly as as a
family and try to have a certain Tech
etiquette around when it's appropriate
to use devices and when it's not when
we're having friends over for a meal you
you shouldn't be on your device you
should be looking in them in the eye
greeting them spending some time talking
not just being so these I think these
are the conversations we really have to
have yeah but does that mean it's not
there's no hope through legislation or
Congress or or lobbying the companies
themselves oh absolutely that's that's
the third piece of it is uh you know the
corporations accountable uh and the way
to do that is really through of various
types of nudges through policy reform
and regulations and just to give an
example I talked about
um thinking that we kids should have as
a top-down policy no smartphones during
school hours
and you know the federal government
could do that by they give lots of funds
to Public Schools you know they could
say either we're not going to give you
as much of those funds unless you manage
uh technology in your school in a
different kind of way or they could
sweeten the pot and say we will give you
more funds if you do something like uh
you know Implement some kind of new
smartphone use policy in your school so
so there there are ways to get in there
and this is there are precedence as well
so for example the age 21 drinking laws
which are now Universal in every state
uh really came to be because the federal
government said well we're not going to
give you Highway funds if you keep your
drinking age lower so so there are ways
to you know kind of create these nudges
it's a strong arms they're called
smartphones right there must be a way I
mean I'm not technically gifted in any
way but you build in a phone and you've
got to have a trust program here where
if it's going to a young person under
the age of 11 or 10 say like that then
it gets time to shut down on usage per
day as you said no more than two hours
or whatever that the limit yeah they're
apps for that surely there is yeah they
do yeah yeah sure they they must then be
mandatory well sir there are lots of
software apps that do that but they're
these kids very early on figure out all
kinds of work all kinds of ways of work
around but what you're implying is that
is actually something that I don't think
has been done to any great degree which
is that there should be Hardware
implementation so for example I you know
I'm not an engineer or a computer
science person but I can imagine a
school laptop that might help especially
for younger children avoid some of the
content that we want them to avoid so
not not just expecting software
companies but also Hardware companies
but but this gets to the whole content
issue which is very hard to regulate
because
um because it's in direct conflict with
privacy laws so for example in some
states I think Louisiana is one of them
they've they've implemented a law that
says in order to sign up for a website
like PornHub you have to prove that you
are uh I think 21 and you have to do
that by uploading your driver's license
but of course nobody is going to go on
PornHub wants to upload their driver's
license and be associated with having
done that so now they've worked out
having like these third-party sites
which kind of anonymously process you
can register with the third party site
yeah and your registration with that
third party site allows you access to
the porn site that's it why do you know
that Chuck because I have a very good
friend
you got a friend you got a friend okay
all right okay so so Professor let's
let's get to the content aspect I mean
it's not just the pool right or online
gambling there is Extreme content that
comes through and it is gay getting
extreme reactions from individuals
you're a psychiatrist
are we higher hardwired to react
extremely to extreme content
let me sharpen that question I I'm all
with it but I want to tune it
specifically because we got to wrap this
up very shortly is
we are seeing content forget the kids
now the adults are being fed content by
the algorithm that enrages us and
motivates us to act in some way and in
the limiting case
it motivates us to commit violence
against the capital
right so
so I it's not so much addiction but
there's definitely a brain thing going
on there that's being fed and that we
can we're reacting in a way that we
think is completely sensible but it's
not when you take one step back from it
yeah and I I think we can hypothesize
that dopamine is involved in this
process too that essentially when we see
when our opinion is validated with a
large group and then we're experiencing
an emotion at the same time that many
other people are experiencing that
emotion that's one of the ways that we
feel connected to other people right
sharing an emotional experience and we
know that feeling connected to other
people releases oxytocin which is our
love hormone which binds to dopamine
receptors in the reward pathway which
then released dopamine so we I think
there is this sense in which we are kind
of getting high off of this group
experience whatever it may be whether
it's you know people watching people
watching other people make music like
now you know it's not just videos of
people making music we watch other
people having a reaction to the music
and that makes it more potent because
we're having a shared emotional
experience if they call reaction videos
yeah they're for everything they I got
it for
I've even been encouraged to get I've
I've posted a reaction video to a tick
tock just for for that context because I
was duly notified by someone one-third
my age on our staff that that was a
thing to do for a particular posting by
another person who made music about the
planets and then I comment I was
reacting to it
very cute it was not that's cool
Professor this sort of safety in numbers
didn't back in mind they used to call
that herd mentality red herd mentality
Feeding Frenzy um these types of things
but I mean yeah what's the term is it
rageaholic
yeah rajaha I mean you know it is
important to realize that you can get
addicted not just to sort of positive
stimuli but actually aversive or
negative you know people Doom scroll
they get addicted to the news they get
addicted to becoming enraged I think
that the addiction phenomenon could even
um apply to like a domestic violence
situation
um where people kind of get addicted to
the uncertainty of that let me just kind
of you know uh violent relationship
um which is maybe why you know sometimes
people keep going back they can't leave
it and what about people jump out of
airplanes for fun
yeah so that's been our research to some
degree and what what they find is that
after the first jump uh there's this
kind of like
um paralyzed Terror in the aftermath but
with with subsequent jumps people get
just frankly euphoric there's an
enormous high but also with people who
jump all the time they develop anhedonia
which is to say they develop a kind of
depressed state there's probably like a
flooding of their brain of
neurotransmitters and then it's too much
and then you have this kind of
compensation so that it's possible and
it's hypothesized even in the literature
well there's an answer studies there's
an answer to that the next jump you make
just do it without the shoot
that's it right or go higher and higher
or whatever it is
okay thank you Chuck for solving that
problem for us here
um Gary Gary we got to close this down
it's been this I know but before we do
what's the next big addiction is it
going to be AI oh my God that sounds
like the worst reality show ever
then that's big addiction
gosh I know I I'm trying to I'm trying
hard to prevent people from getting
addicted we've already seen that movie
it was called her that movie's been made
yeah yeah yes that's right yeah the main
character is addicted to this
this this AI woman on his phone and then
you see everybody around him addicted to
their own uh AI lover right their own
devices yeah right yeah it's because
people were left to their own devices
I saw what you did I saw what I did
there
listen Anna this has been a delight on a
sad topic you've said some important
light on it first of all great stuff and
it clearly doesn't or shouldn't end here
um we will totally find another reason
to bring you back on
um because this is a never-ending
challenge that we all face uh if not for
ourselves but for loved ones or
certainly for Society at large so thank
you for your expertise there and your
your two books uh give me the names of
those again I love the first one what
was that what's that called drug dealer
drug dealer MD great title there who
publishes these by the way
the first is Johns Hopkins University
press and the dopamine nation is
published by Dutton penguin Random House
wow so that means it's got good
distribution there okay we'll look for
that all right uh so Anna thank you for
being on Star Talk
you're welcome thank you for inviting me
all right Chuck Gary we out yep pleasure
all right this has been Neil deGrasse
Tyson your personal astrophysicist for a
Star Talk special edition on the
dictionary until next time as always
looking up
ha
ha stop
[Music]